here with reaction she is the host of
the mornings with Maria on the Fox
Business channel also listen I have to
admit my favorite hour you do is right
here on this channel you have the best
interviews you have been I can never
have you on the show because you gotta
get up but I guess what two three in the
morning yeah I don't go to bed until you
and do see and kill me it and Ainsley
get up so I'm other you know you guys
are all I don't have you do but you do a
great show here you have been all over
this you have done a phenomenal job
great interviews but let's talk about
the liar versus the truth teller Nunez
versus chef yeah
well it's pretty incredible I mean the
lies that came out of Adam Schiff and
Adam shifts office as you just pointed
out it's even worse than lies though
Sean these are crimes committed people
will be prosecuted for this even if you
believe which I do not
William bar does not and John Durham
does not that there was a credible
reason to start the investigation into
Donald Trump that counter investigation
it died within weeks it died within
weeks because they were transcripts of
undercover DOJ agents FBI agents running
into people like George papadopolis Sam
Clovis Carter page and those documents
were the exculpatory evidence that they
did not sent to the FISA Court I think
this really blows up even bigger than it
is right now when obviously John Durham
comes out with his findings but leading
into that all the attention will be on
what happened before July 2016 you know
the lie that the FBI has been telling us
that the counter investigation began in
July of 16 we know that's not true
in fact in the IG report and nobody
really talked about this I thought this
was stunning in the IG report it says
that Christopher Steele was hired by
Glenn Simpson a fusion GPS in May of 16
May of 2016
this was Kimball East Russell's fine
that's right III phoned it on it as well
I don't think many people there saying
the official investigation began what
July 30 31 that's right but that didn't
happen we know that because we know that
Carter Page was invited to all of these
conferences in Cambridge we know George
papadopolis was told go to Rome meet
this guy Joseph Mifsud
and then Joseph mr. drops this bomb on
his lap that Russia
as Hillary Clinton emails that was in
April of 2016
so there were there was a lot of
informants the same informant spies that
have worked with the FBI and the CIA
over the years Western Intel those are
the spies that were running into anybody
they could who is remotely attached to
the Trump campaign as you said earlier
just to get a window into Trump's
strategy so the lies are real people
will be prosecuted and you are looking
at crimes not only against Carter Paige
but against a sitting president duly
elected as you said it and it's what's
really Maria also amazing to me in all
of this is that there were a few of us
that were right and your honor Fox
Business Network and you're here on
weekends with us on the Fox News Channel
but it was you lou dobbs stuart varney
thank all three of you have done the
Trish have done a phenomenal job in
exposing this where's the rest of our
colleagues in the so-called media here
well I think this is a really important
point because the left-wing media has
become an attachment and arm of the
Democratic Party and I've been saying
now for several years anybody on either
side of the aisle has to be outraged by
this because you have people in
positions of power
putting their finger on the scale and
trying to change what the American
people voted for this is a democracy and
we have freedom to elect our leader and
what they did was try to get in front of
that that's why I find it extraordinary
that nobody else in the media wants to
but even worse than that criminal is the
fact that the Democrats refused to focus
on this the same people who have been
calling for impeachment are the people
who tried to take Donald Trump down from
the get-go it was Adam Schiff remember
for three years Sean going on MSNBC and
CNN and everywhere he could get saying
collusion between the Russians and
Donald Trump is in plain sight plain
sight
why is no one asking him where that is
in terms of being in plain sight this
weekend more interviews admit it they
lied they lied because they just didn't
like Donald Trump regardless of the
policies that are moving the needle on
the economy and and among other things
great analysis we see we need Maria more
but she gets up at 2 a.m. and we'd love
to have you
more but you cannot for doing and the
only reason I'll I will concede
tonight's a company Christmas party so
we got to have to stay late
Thank You Maria thank you so much Shawn